dramatische szenen haben sich an diese
mangelware
in der kleinen stadt tornesch am rande
von hamburg abgespielt hier war am
donnerstagabend ein vater mit seiner
neunjährigen tochter auf einem
abendspaziergang beide gingen um dieses
gewässer
als dann plötzlich hinter mir hier an
dieser kannte dieser schwelle zum wasser
das kleine mädchen das gleichgewicht
verlor und ins wasser fiel
der vater handelte sofort überlegte
nicht lange und sprang hinterher doch
tragischerweise konnte weder er noch
seine tochter schwimmen
der mann versuchte sich noch an diesen
bäumen die hier beide hinter mir zu
sehen sind festzuhalten und schaffte es
aber nicht die beiden arme des mädchens
zugreifen und so wieder ans land zu
ziehen
als dann die polizei kam und ersthelfer
hier vor ort eintrafen wurde das mädchen
aus dem wasser geholt dann der vater
doch die traurige nachricht der vater
verstarb nur wenige stunden später in
einem hamburger krankenhaus und unser
reporter konnten mit einem abend zeigen
sprechen
ich habe schreie gehört außen gar also
als ich im garten war habe ich die
tochter schreien hirn um hilfe und das
also man hört ja öfter mal schreier aber
das klang schon mal anders als sonst
sondern bin ich direkt aufs fahrrad
gesprungen bin her gefahren und da wurde
mir schon die tochter aus dem sie von
jemand anderem entgegen gereicht und
dann haben wir gewartet bis die polizei
kam und sind hinterher und haben dann
nur noch den sich nicht mehr bewegen den
vater rausholen können
er hat auch ein segel guckt er sehe da
war nichts keine blase gar nichts
deswegen wussten wir auch nicht wo
sollen wir rein wie tief ist er wohl
ehrlich ich war halt nicht direkt am
anfang da und im nachhinein denke ich
mir also wenn wenn das irgendwer sehen
oder hören sollte bildet eine
menschenkette geht zusammen rein macht
das nicht allein aber macht es irgendwie
dass sie daran kommt und steht nicht
draußen rum weil das könnt ihr euch
selber dann nur vorwerfen also ich werde
es mir vor dass ich nicht früher rein
gegangen bin